Right,
and was promoted and not liking it
because I have to adjust massively.
Is there a difference between liking
your job and the lack of discipline to
perform a change?
Are there,
are they connected?
Yeah.
While they're definitely connected.
It's a tough one.
Um,
the first thing I would say is that if
it was a real radical change,
you know,
it takes people,
unless they're very young,
it takes people about a year to adjust
to a really radical change,
like to move to a new city,
to,
to adjust to being married.
That can take longer than a year to
adjust to having a new baby to,
to getting over a relatively serious
loss,
like a death in the family a year,
you know?
And so the first thing you might ask
yourself is,
are there things that are good about the
promotion?
The second is,
do you have the capacity to do the job
or to learn how to do it?
You could talk to someone about that.
And then the third thing is have you
given yourself enough time to adjust?
Because one of the things I often
recommend to people when they've made a
radical change,
like going leaving home and going to
universities,
don't pay any attention to how you feel
for a year because everything is so much
up in the air that you can't really
trust your own judgment.
So you have to give yourself time to
adapt and um,
you can't expect that that's going to
happen overnight.
It,
it's certainly not.
And to put that expectation on yourself
increases the probability that you're
going to feel bad about it.